she's the tiny flesh-and-blood
embodiment of a medical breakthrough
which will bring hope to thousands of
childless couples the six pound six
ounce baby girl was the first to be born
from the transplanted womb of a dead
woman her mother the transplant
recipient was 32 years old and the only
picture we have of her is a hand drip
attached holding on to her newborn the
transplant was carried out two years ago
by a Brazilian team in South Paulo
though news of a successful birth has
only just been released the donor was a
45 year old who died of a brain
hemorrhage till now only if the woman
has a close friend or a relative that
can donate the oders
she can receive an authoress
transplantation then when you have the
feasibility of this new technique you
can have almost a universal access to
this kind of approach throughout any
sort of cancer diagnosis all you want is
options for Haley Brown who froze
embryos before treatment for cervical
cancer which may leave her infertile the
prospect of another route to motherhood
is potentially life-changing for me to
be able to carry my own child with being
a dream come true because when that
choice is taken away from you and it
makes you think about what's really
important to you and that for me is
really important if it never happens I
will find a way to have family a
different way but if there's a chance
that I could go through the normal and
kind of pregnancy that so many other
people go through and I would love that
opportunity there have already been
babies born after womb transplants from
living donors the first was in Sweden
five years ago and the surgeon who
carried out the procedure has told Sky
News from his clinic in Stockholm there
will be more babies born this way our
team we have done 20 of more than 50
transplants that have done worldwide and
we have now nine babies
one from our cohort of women and we are
we have several ongoing pregnancies so
the effectiveness of the procedure is
big it's probably 80 to 90 percent take
on baby ray if the surgery surgery is
successful the emotional turmoil of
infertility in all its guises is well
documented the news of another pathway
to having a child of their own is
something else to cling on to for
couples across the world
Debbie Bowden Sky News